nos dicen que cada cuadrado grande
representa un entero expresa el área
sombreada como un número mixto y también
como undécima pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver cómo se puede expresar esto
como un número mixto y cómo sería en
decimal
ok vamos a resolverlo juntos empecemos
con el número mixto aquí tenemos un
entero todo el cuadrado está sombreado
entonces tenemos un entero y de este
lado solo hay una parte sombreada este
cuadrado está dividido en 10 secciones
iguales y solamente dos de ellas están
sombreadas así que como número mixto
podemos decir que tenemos un entero y
después tenemos 2 de 10 partes
sombreadas por lo tanto esto es igual a
un entero dos décimos
y listo observen que esta parte está
dividida en décimos y solo hay dos de
esas partes quién es y qué me dicen del
decimal
bueno simplemente expresemos un entero
dos décimos en decimal porque esto es
igual a 1 y después nos movemos a la
posición de las décimas en donde sólo
tenemos 2 así que esto es igual a 1.2
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí tenemos algo
más complicado nuevamente nos dicen que
cada cuadrado grande representa un
entero y nuevamente nos piden que
expresemos el área sombreada como
fracción iv decimal pause en el vídeo y
traten de resolver bien empecemos
nuevamente con la fracción aquí tenemos
un entero dos enteros y después tenemos
un tercer entero pero que está
parcialmente sombreado entonces si
queremos expresar todo esto como una
fracción nuevamente podemos escribir un
número mixto vamos a ver todo esto
corresponde a 12
pero de este lado solo tenemos una parte
sombreada y observen que se encuentra
dividida en centésimas porque tenemos
una cuadrícula de 10 por 10 así que cada
uno de estos cuadros representa un
centésimo del entero pero cuántos de
esos centésimos están sombreados bueno
aquí tenemos 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 y
después tenemos 71 234 podemos ver que
74 cuadros de los 100 que hay están
sombreados así que como número mixto
todo esto representa dos enteros y 74
centésimas y si ahora queremos
escribirlo en decimal tenemos dos
enteros y después nos ubicamos en la
posición de las décimas aunque
simplemente podríamos escribir dos
enteros y 74 centésimas así pero también
lo pueden ver como cuantas décimas y
centésimas es porque en este caso
tenemos uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete décimas
y después cuatro centésimas más así que
lo pueden ver como 74 centésimas o siete
décimas y cuatro centésimas pero de
cualquier manera ya terminamos